how's it going guys i want to talk a
little bit about to
the right to repair because it's a thing
that's going on a thing that's uh
going to be changing in the world coming
up and you could be a part of it we
we need as many people as we can get
pretty much now this is something that
is kind of near and dear to my heart
because i've been
well i've been i've been on this side of
it i've worked for
repair centers and i've been in there
taking stuff apart fixing it
placing parts soldering new things on
i've done that there's some real
issues here and i want to talk about a
little bit now there is this site
i don't know if this is the main thing
for it i'm going to show you a couple
other things too
now the way i mainly heard about the
recent happenings of this
was from a guy named louis rossman which
i'll show you his channel here real
quick
uh yeah lewis rossman who does a bunch
of videos about fixing macbooks and
stuff like that he just owns a little
shop where he does it you've probably
heard of him he's he's pretty
popular on youtube and stuff but yeah
i've been here
i've done this i've taken part macbooks
i fixed them but when i did it i was
going through official channels
i had to uh yeah
like when something went wrong with a
macbook you pretty much had to open a
ticket with apple
you couldn't repair any of this stuff
you weren't allowed to fix a motherboard
or anything like that you basically had
to send the old parts back
and they would send you a new one so you
weren't really allowed to touch anything
with the macbooks we could we were
basically allowed to open them up
and run the tests and send parts and get
parts we weren't really allowed to do
anything else than that
now that's just one company of course
there's other companies involved in this
too
all right and just to say a few more
things on when i actually worked for a
company that did
some of these repairs and it was like uh
it was a well known well not well known
it was an official company well i don't
want to say the exact name of it but
to get all the apple manuals and
diagnostics and the stuff to do your own
repair
you weren't allowed apple would only
give that
to certified repair centers they would
not give
any of the stuff to repair your own own
things
to consumers now that this was like
quite a few years ago so
are they coming around i don't know i'm
not in that world anymore but it was
definitely a thing and it was the same
with other companies too
it was the same with dell and hp that
you could find some stuff
but you could find some of the manuals
you could actually find a lot of the
technical manuals for
hp and dell i think you could find most
of those
but they're kind of hard to find but the
apple ones you could not you had to
actually be a certified center
just any consumer couldn't get them so
even as the certified repair center that
i worked at
we would often have to torrent tools
because they were not available to fix
people's stuff
and it was stuff that was under warranty
and we were a
repair center that was supposed to be
able to do it and
we literally couldn't find the
documentation unless we went and hacked
it so
obviously we didn't tell anyone this
some of us repair guys would just be
like hey man i got this tool it's really
useful
we need it and we would just be like all
right let's you know let's do it just
hush hush it's going to save everybody
tons of time and that you know
it was it was bizarre to have to use
those methods
just because of this kind of stuff
all right back to editing uh so let's
talk about this website now i don't know
who runs this website i just found it
through
the google search by googling right to
repair i don't know if
mr rossman is involved in this but it
does have some info
and i think it's good info as far as i
can tell correct me
if i'm wrong so let's just look a little
bit
um on this site and see what we can find
well let's let's start on the home site
okay
so the bottom line here is is what they
say right on the front here so i'm just
going to read it we have the right to
repair
everything we own some big things repair
jobs are
local jobs this is true this is one of
my
you know i had a job doing this stuff
and it was local and it was
something that helped me and i i learned
a lot from it so
it is a real thing if
you know if we don't get to do this
everything's just going to get shipped
to the main company and we're going to
have some
some group in a warehouse somewhere
fixing it and the local people won't be
able to do anything
so it would be all bad why do we need
the right to repair
yeah that's the first question i'm going
to ask because it's like it's your stuff
do what you want with it like who's
gonna
tell you any different but apparently
you could potentially get sued and stuff
like that for
modifying your own stuff or fixing your
own stuff which blows my mind and
as far as we can tell that is illegal so
let's just uh read this the presence
of technology parts of modern equipment
has enabled manufacturers to reduce
access to repair by proclaiming
that repair might violate their
proprietary rights
this is a marketing ruse and not
grounded in law yeah that's
that's what we always knew it as pretty
much even when we're repairing stuff we
would even tell customers that we would
say
that yeah they're going to try to make
you buy a new one if something goes
wrong
they're going to say i don't want to
mess with it just buy a new one or trade
it in
when you don't need to do that sometimes
it's a really simple fix
sometimes it's just a little bit of
education and you can
save yourself a ton of time and money
and all kinds of stuff but
but if that happens then the company
doesn't make their additional 800
or whatever so yeah it is it is often a
marketing ruse
and it's pretty obnoxious all right
manufacturers do not have any rights to
control property beyond the sale
limitations on repair
become a serious problem for all modern
equipment also limits how equipment can
be traded on the used market the best
primer for this topic is
the end of ownership by renown
law professor aaron person i'm sure i
said that wrong but i'll try to find
this and link it below the enter
ownership
sounds like a pretty interesting read on
the topic
and yeah something has been going on for
a while so all right let's
read a few more of these why is
legislation needed in the states
most current limitations on repair are
made in contracts
such as end user license agreements that
have agreed
limit how equipment can be used if you
bought the thing
you should be able to use it how you
want contracts full under the general
business law in the states
legislation for right to repair is
typically assigned to committees
handling general business
law so the people that handle this
have nothing to do with it that's that
annoys me you know
like the people that know how to do this
stuff people that might know how to fix
it
or might know what they're doing have no
say in it
currently it's just businessmen and
suits who have no idea they're
just reading paperwork and you know sign
it that sort of thing
isn't repair illegal under copyright law
no
the u.s copyright office concluded in
december 2016 that
poor interpretation of the copyright law
has led to confusion
but the copyright law does not restrict
repairing
tinkering customization security
research
or resale you're we're already allowed
to do this
so this actually makes me question if
it's not
currently illegal then why do we need
this just just do it like they're not
gonna
they can't do anything if it's not
currently illegal i i think in in simple
binary terms
you know if it's not illegal under
copyright law maybe there's some other
law
but if the answer is no then you
continue on with your life and stop
wasting your time basically you know
that's that's like the programmer way
if true continue type of thing
in this case if not false whatever well
headphones off real talk all right let's
just let's just continue
i'm gonna pretend i didn't i'm gonna
pretend this said yes
now this has become an april fool's
video
not intentional not intentional what
would the legislation change the bill
requires original equipment
manufacturers provide consumers and
independent repair
business people equal access to repair
documents diagnostic
tools service parts and firmware okay so
i guess this is probably the big thing
and probably answers the previous
question
so repair isn't illegal but
if you don't have the information to
know how to repair it because
the company won't release repair
documents or diagnostics or tools or
firmware if they keep that all internal
and proprietary and say hey if you have
a problem
you have to come to us because we have
all the stuff
and we won't release it that's probably
where the problem comes in
so i imagine this bill might work
to basically force them to release all
this stuff
for this equipment that you buy
so maybe that's how this works uh
together
because sure it's not illegal but if you
can't get the things you need
because it's proprietary and you
basically would have to spend
i don't know 10 years of your life
reverse engineering or something
well when the info is already out there
i guess this would probably force them
to release the stuff they should have
already released
how does this impact customer choice
local repair and resale businesses would
not exist
without consumers purchasing
manufactured products
rights to repair or fair repair
legislation is for consumer rights to
choose
all the stuff
all right what will happen to retailers
nothing all right
this uh right to repair falls only on
the manufacturers
not the distributors retails or
franchises
all right so there's a bunch of other
stuff here
i've heard of auto right to repair is it
similar absolutely right to repair is
current law for auto repairs
okay so yeah i guess there's a thing
with
vehicles where you have the right to
repair your own vehicle now let's move
to electronics as we move forward
yep so you can go sign here and uh it
might help some you might as well it's
free to do but uh you can also support
lewis and his whole lobbying effort
that's probably going to be the bigger
deal i would imagine
uh in this case because you have to do
all this stuff and get all the ads and
everything
this is just going to need to be pushed
as much as possible
i think it's inevitable basically at
some point
but uh yeah the word needs to get out
there so if you have
extra money to donate feel free
you know all right well that's basically
it just wanted to bring awareness to
that instead of
instead of making a troll april fool's
video i figured i'd actually do
something
somewhat useful and just uh talk about
this a little bit
is yeah it's it's a real thing and a lot
of
a lot of people are losing money because
i just have to go through the official
and get way overcharged or rebuy the
same thing and it's uh
it's not necessary it's not required
it's just the way the companies are
setting it up let's stop this big tech a
little bit and actually
be allowed to spread knowledge because
you know that's also
what i'm about here this is about
spreading knowledge
and that it's very relevant to a lot of
different things because of that
like if if we have the right to repair
and we
well we do if they actually release
these documents
that's just going to increase the
overall knowledge level of everyone out
there as we're allowed to go do our own
research
and not have to be i don't know
just have things hidden basically that
shouldn't be to begin with
all right that's it for this video see
you guys
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
knowledge